I was really wondering I was 50 50 on
whether or not you were going to be
doing your interviews shirtless I wish I
could I hate wearing shirts and I've
gained weight so none of my shirts fit
me right now well my question is did the
studio or a publicist say yeah you're
wearing a shirt today oh yeah oh I have
they have shirts for every thing I'm
supposed to do and I'm so fat I can't
fit in them so I I end up taking them
off in the middle of the interview
anyway because it my buttons are just
bulging so what you're trying to say is
publicist do have I'm going to make a
joke publishes have some control but not
all the control
publish this and my wife my wife picked
out the shirts too
um so listen man um you've done a lot in
terms of comedy specials podcasts you've
put a lot out there if someone has
actually never heard you before or seen
you before what's like the first thing
you want them watching oh that's the
greatest question
I I want them to watch
oh [__]
if someone's never seen me before I
think I want them to watch the machine
story I think I want them to watch the
machine story I was gonna say two bears
one cave because I feel like that's that
I I share so much about who I am on that
podcast but but then you got to meet Tom
too and he's a snooze Fest so it's gonna
be the machine story you get to have
Mark Hamill as play your dad in this
movie and I wanted to know how long did
it take you on set before you started
peppering him with like Star Wars
questions and like you know because
you're of the age that you grew up with
Star Wars yeah oh yeah I saw in the
movie theater I saw Return of the Jedi
in the movie theater and on the ride
home I tried to get my Chewbacca doll to
met to lift I like I was obsessed with
Star Wars I was obsessed with Star Wars
um
I asked in rehearsals I was asking him
questions and like right when I first
met him I was hammering him for every
and I was asking like does does
Harrison's Ford smoke pot like like
though I was asking him like grown-up
questions too I was like I was like
obsessed with Carrie Fisher's energy
like in life so I I loved her I loved
her and so I guess she's got to Deep
dive everything he was and I wanted to
know I wanted to know like who were
people who were supposed to play the
roles and like he had all that I didn't
know that Harrison Ford was just helping
read sides with other people like I
think Tom Selleck was supposed to play
Han Solo and then it was awesome he was
awesome and he took the time to tell you
everything like he gets that the weight
of of your dreams and hopes rests on him
being cool to you like you know there's
a lot of celebrities who dropped the
ball on that and Mark Hamill does not
yeah listen man I I am uh listen I'm a
huge fan I mean I you know Star Wars
means a lot to me so this is your first
time I believe being number one on the
call sheet and you're the lead of like a
Hollywood movie what actually surprised
you about you know like uh filming a
movie like this and maintaining like the
energy every day because it's like from
what I understand it's like a marathon
when you're filming yeah oh uh so I
never really understood like uh actors
needing to be in character and stuff
like I can get it like I just never
acted and in most of this movie I'm just
playing myself so like I just I'm in
character every day when I show up to
work
and then there was one scene where in
the rehearsal we're doing it in the
rehearsal and uh I accessed some emotion
and I started to tear up and the actress
my actual Eva babic was like that was
really good you should do that in the
thing and I go I don't know if I can and
she's well he she and she told me she
goes go be by yourself and don't lose
this energy and bring it back in and
we'll do it and we'll get you and and
the director was cool I had never been
there it was the coolest thing about
acting is like I'm all sudden in this
tent like thinking about my daughter and
like our relationship was a little Rocky
and I accessed that and I was like this
is [__] cool and then I was like oh
dude I want to see what Daniel Day Lewis
does like all sudden you're like this is
amazing so yeah that was like the
challenge I think when legendary
acquired the rights to your story to to
make the machine uh they you know film
studios acquire rights all the time but
that doesn't actually mean it's going to
move forward so when did you realize oh
[__] this is actually gonna happen I did
Peter atencio came to my house it was a
bottle of blands and and we have been
Greenland I still didn't know what that
meant I'm being dead serious I did not
know what that meant and he opened a
bottle of lands he's like so we're
making this movie and I was like but
people are saying that the entire time
yeah we're making a movie we're making a
movie and I go yeah yeah and he goes no
like I go to Serbia tomorrow and I went
what are you going to Serbia for and he
goes starting to scout locations I go
hold on
like are you being paid and he was like
dude my deal is closed we're he's he
goes get ready we're making a movie in a
month and I was like shut the f I really
had no clue until we opened that bottle
of blantons yeah I mean but it happens
all the time where people you know hey
making a movie getting a green light is
really hard yeah
it's impossible I mean I can't believe I
feel like I got really lucky I feel like
do you ever see those videos on
Instagram where the lady walks out in
traffic and a bus misses her by a minute
sure that's what I feel like I feel like
a bunch of buses just miss me and I'm
just standing here going how did I get
here like this is crazy yeah I'm really
I'm really really really lucky I got
lucky and I got lucky to be surrounded
by like and I'm I know you people say
this and they don't mean it but like
just crazy talented people that all knew
what the [__] they were doing oh 100
um when what are you most looking
forward to your fans actually seeing in
the movie uh I I think there's a lot of
things there's like deep Dives like I
I'm excited that they're gonna see
things that weren't in the trailer
that's what I'm excited about like I
have one friend who saw a trail a
screener a guy a radio show and he his
comment was you didn't put all the funny
parts in the trailer this movie is
[__] awesome and I was like yes
that's it like I I have spoilers inside
I have like little Easter eggs in the
movie like I spray painted Thomas fat
like there's little things like that
like the guy whose head we rip off is a
UFC champion good friends with Rogan
like I'm excited for people to like find
the little things that are like Easter
eggs you know what was there a day that
you thought someone was going to be
super simple to film and it ended up
being a huge pain in the ass
no no no I
I I got to be honest with you I I really
just loved every second of it I really
felt like every day was the first date
and so everything we did was was just a
blast the uh the the thing the one thing
that's like was was tedious for me I
have tactile issues right like in
America we're a little more sensitive to
like people's people's mental health and
uh I didn't like when they put blood on
me and I had to have blood on me for
half the movie it was sticky it was
uncomfortable and it had to be all over
my hands and that was the most tedious
and they'd just be like put it on and
I'd be like well can we wait until I eat
or like like and then once it was on I
was like this the whole day because I
was sticky and so that was the only part
of the movie that I was like Ugh I would
never be able to sit through like uh uh
be like one of those like like Eddie
Murphy would do the the clubs and do all
that makeup I could never do that I
would be like I would be losing my mind
yeah I think a lot of people don't
realize uh you you hit the nail on the
head especially if you're filming like a
zombie movie you know and you have to be
in that makeup no [__] way no way and
that note I gotta go I'm just gonna say
congrats on the movie I really do hope
it's a huge hit for you brother thank
you so much from your mouth to God's
ears